THAT’S MY OPEN.
LET ME KNOW WHAT YOU THINK ON MY
FACEBOOK TWITTER,
#judgejeanine.
THE LATESTEN WASHINGTON’S FIGHT
AGAINST THE CORONAVIRUS, HOUSE
MINORITY LEADER AND CALIFORNIA
CONGRESSMAN KEVIN McCARTHY.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
CONGRESSMAN, I WOULD LIKE TO
START WITH WHERE I ENDED ON THE
OPEN.
THAT’S THE ISSUE OF CHINA AND
THE FACT THEY WERE NOT
TRANSPARENT.
THEY HID INFORMATION FROM US.
OUR OWN INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
TOLD US THEY WERE HIDING
INFORMATION ABOUT THIS VIRUS AND
AS A RESULT WE ARE SUFFERING AND
WE HAVEN’T HIT THE APEX IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
CONGRESS, WHAT YOU ARE GOING TO
DO WHEN THIS PANDEMIC IS OVER?
>> YOU ARE CORRECT.
THIS IS A CHINA, COMMUNIST
COVER-UP.
THE DOCTOR WHO GAVE THE WARNING,
WE CANNOT FIND HIM ANYMORE.
JUDGE JEANINE: HE’S DEAD.
>> THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHAMPTON
DID A STUDY.
IF CHINA HAD BEEN HONEST WITH
THE WORLD, 95% LESS PEOPLE WOULD
HAVE BEEN SICK.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN CONTROLLED
AND CONTAINED IN CHINA.
NOW WHAT WE ARE FINDING AND YOU
ARE WATCHING CHINA STILL OPEN UP
THESE WET MARKETS.
HAVEN’T ENOUGH PEOPLE DIED FOR
THEM TO UNDERSTAND?
HASN’T THERE BEEN ENOUGH
FINANCIAL DESTRUCTION AROUND THE
WORLD HE SINGLE DAY, AND THEY
CONTINUE TO DENY IT?
THEIR OWN NUMBERS ARE A LIE.
THERE WAS A RECENT STUDY.
THEY ESTIMATE 43,000 PEOPLE DIED
IN WUHAN.
WE’LL NOT KNOW BECAUSE THEY
KILLED THE DOCTORS.
AND BECAUSE OF THEIR COVER-UP WE
ARE HAVING MORE THAN A ANY
PEOPLE HAVE THIS VIRUS AND THE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DIED.
JUDGE JEANINE: THERE IS ALSO
TALK ABOUT IN ADDITION TO THE
WET MARKETS.
THERE IS TALK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT THERE WAS THIS BIO
SCEPTICAL LAB WITHIN A FEW
HUNDRED YARDS OF THE WET MARKET.
WHAT HAVE YOU HEARD ABOUT THAT?
>> THEY HAVE A FACILITY THERE.
MOST DOCTORS WILL TELL YOU IT
CAME FROM THE WET MARKET.
THEY SHOULD CLOSE THOSE WET
MARKETS AND NOT HAVE THEM MOVING
FORWARD.
BUT WHAT’S EVEN WORSE.
WHY WE ARE FIGHTING THIS VIRUS
IN AMERICA AND AROUND THE WORLD,
YOU KNOW WHAT CHINA IS DOING?
WE HAVE GOT TO CHANGE THE SUPPLY
CHAIN.
THEY CONTROL SO MUCH OF THE
PERSONAL PROTECTION EQUIPMENT WE
NEED FOR OUR MEDICAL.
THEY CONTROL SO MANY WHEN IT
COMES TO OUR PHARMACEUTICALS.
BUT NOW WHAT THEY ARE DOING,
THEY WILL ONLY SELL TO COUNTRIES
IF THEY AGREE TO BUY THEIR OWN
TECHNOLOGY, HUAWEI INSIDE CHINA.
ANOTHER INDUSTRY WITH ANOTHER
SUPPLY CHAIN.
THAT’S WRONG.
>> THAT’S CLEARLY WRONG.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS GETTING
LEVERAGE AND ACCESS THROUGH
THEIR TECHNOLOGY TO WHAT WE ARE
DOING AGAIN.
THIS IS THE PROBLEM.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE PANDEMIC THAT
HAD ITS GENESIS IN CHINA.
THEN WE TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT
WHATEVER TREATIES WE MAY HAVE
WITH FOR COUNTRIES TO GET
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT WE
ARE NOT GETTING.
THEN YOU HAVE THE ISSUE OF THE
SUPPLY CHAIN.
WHY ARE WE NOT GETTING WHAT WE
NEED AND MAKE WHAT WE NEED IN
THE UNITED STATES.
DONALD TRUMP IS THE FIRST
PRESIDENT I HAVE HEARD TALK
ABOUT AMERICA FIRST, MADE IN
AMERICA.
THEY LOVED AT HIM ON THE LEFT.
NOW WE REALIZE WE ARE VULNERABLE
BECAUSE WE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP WARNED
AMERICA AND WASHED THE WORLD.
THIS IS WHAT ACAMPAIGNED ON.
BUT HE’S -- WHAT HE CAP PAINED -
CAMPAIGNED ON.
BUT HE WAS HELD UP BECAUSE ALL
THEY WANTED TO DO WAS IMPEACH
HIM.
CHINA HAS BEEN ALLOWED TO HAVE
THIS CONTROL OVER THE REST OF
THE WORLD.
BECAUSE THEY CONTROL THE SUPPLY
CHAIN THEY ARE TRYING TO CONTROL
WHO CAN GET THE PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT TO THEIR
MEDICAL INDIVIDUALS AND HOLD IT
FOR RANSOM BASED ON GETTING
ANOTHER CONTROL IN ANOTHER
INDUSTRY.
WHY CAN’T WE BRING THAT BACK TO
AMERICA.
WE NEED TO CONTROL OUR MINERALS,
WE NEED TO CONTROL WHEN IT COMES
TO MEDICAL EQUIPMENT.
IT SHOULD BE HERE IN AMERICA AND
NOT LET ANY OTHER COUNTRY HAVE
CONTROL OVER US OR ANY PLACE IN
THE WORLD.
JUDGE JEANINE: ONE OF THE THINGS
UP ON THE SCREEN WAS THE
CORONAVIRUS CAMPAIGN.
WHAT’S INTERESTING IS ON MARCH 4
CHINESE STATE MEDIA THREATENED
TO CUT OFF CRITICAL U.S. DRUG
SUPPLIES.
THEN THEY PUSHED THE THEORY THAT
THE U.S. MILITARY STARTED THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC.
MARCH 19 THEY REPORT NO NEW
LOCAL CASES.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT?
>> I DON’T BELIEVE THAT AT ALL.
THEIR NUMBERS ARE A LIE.
WE KNOW FROM THE STUDY THE
NUMBERS WOULD HAVE BEEN IF THEY
HAD BEEN HONEST.
WE HAVE TO GO INTO THE OTHER
CHAINS OF EVENTS CHINA IS TRYING
TO CONTROL.
THE PART ABOUT THIS PRESIDENT
TRUMP WARNED FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE THAT
DECISION TO STOP THE SPREAD BY
DISALLOWING THE PLANES COMING
FROM CHINA.
JOEJOE BIDEN JUST NOW AGREED
YESTERDAY, HE’S SO FAR BEHIND.
JUDGE JEANINE: WHY * -- JOE JOE
NANCY PELOSI CAN TRY ALL SHE
WANTS TO WITH THIS NEW
COMMITTEE.
>> THERE ARE THREE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEES.
THE LEADERS INSIDE THE HOUSE AND
SENATE APPOINT ANOTHER
INDIVIDUAL.
BUT YOU KNOW IT’S POLITICS WHEN
YOU LOOK AT WHO NANCY PELOSI
WANTS TO APPOINT.
CLYBURN.
HE SAID THE CORONAVIRUS GIVES
HIM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RESTRUCTURE GOVERNMENT IN THEIR
LIBERAL VISION.